Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and her fellow
boat Bolsheviks have finally released
the draft text of the so called green
new deal and it turns out that the green
new deal actually is communism green is
the new red we will analyze the proposal
line by line I've got it right here then
another prominent Democrat wears
blackface is there is there gonna be any
Democrat left in America who has an out
worn blackface president Trump addresses
the National Prayer Breakfast and
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Nolan
this is the Michael Knowles show
I didn't think it was possible I thought
that I had been exaggerating about the
green New Deal the green New Deal is
what Alexandria cassia Cortes in
particular but a lot of these incoming
Democrats these far left-wing Democrats
have been focusing on they want to make
it a central campaign issue and I've
said oh it's just Bolshevism oh it's
communism oh it's but I didn't know
until I saw it I have read the draft
legislation I have read the frequently
asked questions that they have released
we will go through it line by line it is
pure communism we'll get to that in a
second but first let's talk about Ally
Oh Ally is really really good your dog's
health is as important as every other
member of your family and it starts with
what you feed them but do you know what
is in your dog's food ally puts dogs
first with vet formulated recipes and
fully transparent ingredients to give
your dog the healthiest food possible
fresh meals for dogs with real
ingredients that people can eat people
can eat this food they beat out
store-bought dog food ten to one on the
palatability scale all-natural
ingredients no preservatives source from
us family for farms go to my alley
dot-com answer a few questions about
your dog that will customize recipes for
your dog ship pre-portioned will see
your pup gets the perfect portion every
time they've delivered five million
meals and Counting shipping is free the
reason this is important is according to
the FDA most dog food contains meat from
the four DS diseased dead disabled and
dying animals that includes roadkill and
euthanized dogs turn your dog into a
cannibal it doesn't have to be this way
we all care about our health especially
when it comes to what weed so why should
it be any different when it comes to our
pets Olli is listening our listeners 60%
off your first box plus a free bag of
treats at my alley comm slash try slash
Knowles Canada wles this is the best
deal they have available anywhere go to
my alley comm slash try slash an old
Skinner wles 60% off plus a free bag of
treats my oh l li e.com slash try slash
Noel's cane or WL e s check it out it's
very important this is really really
important to remember this because once
the green new deal goes into effect the
best we can hope for is to
eat dog food so I mean all of the other
if it was gonna be gone they're gonna be
bread lines so hopefully at least the
dog food will be consumable by humans
this will be able to have it the green
New Deal the green New Deal is so
left-wing that even Nancy Pelosi is
against it this is how Nancy Pelosi
Democrat speaker of the house
progressive hero this is how she
described it she was asked what do you
think about the green New Deal she said
it will be one of several or maybe many
suggestions that we receive the green
dream or whatever they call it
nobody knows what it is but they're for
it right Nancy stop making me laugh I'm
sick you're gonna hurt my chest even
Nancy Pelosi thinks that this thing is a
pipe dream I've read the draft
legislation I've read the the frequently
asked questions the frequently asked
questions part of this which has been
released by the green New Deal people it
reads like a seventh grade homework
assignment not just in the language
which is also not great but in the idea
it's it's as though you said to seventh
graders hate all right kids we're gonna
have an imaginative learning exercise
dream up your perfect society and then
they all dream up with their little
crayons writing backwards they say oh
and then everybody's gonna do exactly
what I want and money is gonna come from
the sky and Lolly pun it's the gumdrop
candy mountain I mean this is what
American communists and socialists have
been talking about for a hundred years
and they actually reference that in the
legislation here is Alexandra Ocasio
curtains describing what the green new
deal means as you know congresswoman one
reason that people who are politically
conservative are skeptical of efforts to
combat climate change is that it sounds
to them like it requires massive
government intervention which they just
don't like are you prepared to put on
the table that
yes actually they're right what this
requires is massive government
interventions it does yeah I have no
problem saying that she has no problem
saying it's big government interference
she has no problem saying it's a massive
government spent
program this is a difference I mean this
is a market difference from the
progressives I guess from the time of
really FDR though certainly from the
time of Lyndon Johnson but really I
guess FDR even when progressives and
left wingers want to spend a lot of your
money and they usually pretend that
they're not doing it they'll say no no
it's not that big a deal no it's not
it'll be covered by this cement this
event alexandria casio cortez is saying
no we are gonna spend a ton of money you
remember she launched her congressional
career not by protesting trumpet by
protesting nancy pelosi sitting in in
her office about the green new deal and
you're probably wondering why is this
woman who's a socialist that's her main
issue of socialism
why is she focusing on environmentalism
why it's the green new deal it's for
environmental regulations why is it the
answer to that question explains why
conservatives remain skeptical of global
warming why conservatives are skeptical
of plans to come back global warming
this is she's really exposed to the
environmentalist movement for what it is
which is socialism by the back door so
let's take a look at some of the draft
legislation for the green new deal scope
of the plan for the green new deal and
the draft legislation the plan for a
green new deal shall be developed with
the objective of reaching the following
outcomes within the target window of ten
years from the start of execution of the
plan they've got a ten-year plan
chairman mao had a five-year plan or was
it stalin i don't know one of the stew
it a five-year plan and alexandria quart
okazu cortez is a ten-year plan one
dramatically expand existing renewable
power resources and deploy new
production capacity with the goal of
meeting one hundred percent of national
power demand through renewable resources
so what she's saying is no gas no oil no
coal none of that
we're going to meet within ten years
we're gonna get rid of all of our
sources of energy other than renewable
what does renew is that the
windmills that kill all those birds that
produce approximately zero percent of
our national energy is that what she's
talking about just to put this in
perspective right now how do we I think
the left
they're very confused on the specifics
they only learn broad trends so they
don't know actually how the numbers
break down right now natural gas
constitutes 32 percent of our national
energy 32 percent coal constitutes 18
percent of our nation's energy supply
liquid natural gas and oil twenty-eight
percent of our energy supply and then
this for some reason the green New Deal
even eliminates nuclear nuclear energy
doesn't add co2 to the environment it
doesn't create air pollution so it's
extraordinarily efficient as a form of
energy but but it's a key it's they
don't like it because it's tied to I
don't know the Cold War or something
they think of it as so they want to get
rid of nuclear to nuclear provides ten
percent of our energy so how much of the
RN is something like eighty seven
percent for something of our national
energy she's gonna get rid of within ten
years and somehow you know between ten
and twenty percent of our national
energy they're going that's going to
constitute 100 percent of our national
energy supply within ten years how many
jobs do you think that would destroy if
you took away just even obviously what a
wreck or account we're talking about the
energy that fuels our whole economy but
then even just looking at the people who
work in those sectors it would destroy
five point eight million jobs like that
it would destroy five point eight
million jobs by government Fiat the plan
goes on they would upgrade every
residential and industrial building for
state of the art energy efficiency
comfort and safety did you upgrade every
not just industrial every residential
and industrial building every building
in the United States would be ripped
apart and then reconstructed as
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez once a to do
you like your house if you like your
house you can't keep your house
beautiful
old mansions you know the old buildings
all the wonderful old buildings in New
York Oh San Francisco rip down no more
none of that it all has to be redone
according to the central plan devised in
2019 by this ridiculous empty-headed
Bolshevik who pretends that she grew up
in the Bronx I have to get that in there
because even even the boretz of
Alexandria Cassio cortezes political
platform that are sort of endearing
you know she's young she's bubbly her
upbringing even that largely is is a
force the green New Deal goes on
eliminating greenhouse gas emissions
from repairing and improving
transportation and other infrastructure
okay now you might have gotten a little
lost in there they're going to eliminate
greenhouse gas emissions from
transportation
well that doesn't just mean trains that
doesn't that means airplanes that means
your own car so within ten years your
automobile is outlawed air travel
outlawed unless they come up with some
new magic airplane that flies on dreams
and gumdrops and hope air travel
outlawed cars that burn gas outlawed so
I guess it would allow for electric cars
but also you have to ask yourself where
do you think electricity comes from does
it do you think it comes from magic do
you think it just comes from the air no
it comes from burning coal a lot of
other buzz so the even the idea that
we'll just fuel it on electricity is
absurd where are you going to get the
electricity we're on earth does and then
there's a further irony which is that
all of these electric or hybrid cars
Tesla Prius or terrible for the
environment because in building those
batteries it creates far more
environmental destruction than burning
fossil fuels unless you keep your prius
for you know 20-some odd years or
something which i don't know if you've
ever been around those course they don't
last that long and they're very very
expensive to maintain okay part b we're
not even on Part B yet where we've
already destroyed the American
to me we've already killed off on most
six million jobs we've already ruined
your house you don't get your house
anymore we've already taken away your
car we're not on Part B we'll get to
Part B in a second but first let's make
a little money honey with purple
mattress this is where you're gonna have
nice dreams not nightmares like our
current prospective public policy but
you have really nice dreams on purple
mattress you know that I'm a proselyte
Iser for purple mattress I love it so
much it has saved for my marriage I you
know I've I believe I have the flu I got
it but like a couple days ago I really
came down with all the symptoms and uh I
got to tell you I credit getting a
little bit better with my purple
mattress because I lie down in my purple
mattress I'm asleep instantly it is not
a memory foam it's not a an innerspring
it's it's sort of this new technology
which on top of the couple layers of
memory foam has this thing developed by
a rocket scientist it's it's both firm
and soft at the same time how is that
possible I you just have to try it it
the mattress is it sleeps cool but
you're not you know you can obviously
you control your temperature it's just
really really nice a hundred night risk
free trial if you're not fully satisfied
you can return your mattress for a full
refund
backed by ten year warranty free
shipping and returns you're gonna love
purple right now my listeners will get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
a mattress that's in addition to the
great free gifts are offering site-wide
text khofifah Co V Fe Fe two four seven
four seven four seven this is the only
way to get this free pillow CoV f EF e
two four seven four seven four seven
message and data rates will apply maybe
that'll I don't know you know your cell
phone better than I do Part B of the
green New Deal the plan for a green new
deal and the draft legislation she'll
recognize that a national industrial
economic mobilization of this scope in
scale is an historic opportunity to
virtually eliminate poverty in the
United States and to make prosperity
wealth and economic security available
to everyone participating in this
transformation this reads like the Bill
of Rights of some Banana Republic some
tin-pot dictatorship some ridiculous
utopian scheme
either by a Latin American dictator or
by a freshman in college after like four
too many hits on the bong that's what
that reads what has happened just in the
course of history even the course of
American history when we have tried to
eliminate poverty how has that worked
out as that people have tried it since
the dawn of time how has that ever
worked no to quote Ronald Reagan we
fought a war on poverty and poverty one
the poor will always be with us
as a wise man said so that's that this
when you look down into even just Part B
you say oK we've been talking about
energy crazy plans - for renewable
energy and the environment but okay but
now what does this have to do with the
environment we're going to eliminate
poverty we're going to make prosperity
wealth and economic security available
to everyone in this transformation now
you get to what they're really after
which is that this green New Deal is
just a facade for socialism all that
green and that green is just a little a
little patina on top of the real color
which is red it is socialism and
actually this plan goes all the way to
communism number one provide all members
of our society across all regions in all
communities the opportunity training and
education to be a full participant in
the transition including through a job
guarantee program to assure a living
wage to every person who wants one a job
guarantee program okay now this is a
little tricky
who doesn't want a job Bunz I guess
don't want jobs or the retired don't
want a job or kids little kids don't
want jobs the job guarantee program is
the great example of a government that
is big enough to give you everything you
want being big enough to take away
everything that you have because part of
the job guarantee program this has been
touted in a lot of different places by
proponents of the green New Deal is that
it does away with the need to have an
unemployment insurance you've got a job
guarantee the government is the
stop for employment if you go to the
Green Party's website they have the the
more fully fleshed-out version of the
green New Deal
they lay this out explicitly that that
line is only implicit in this
legislation though it is implicit but
why would you have unemployment
insurance when the government is your
your final backstop okay maybe that
sounds good but then what does that mean
it means that the government just from
Part one of the legislation the
government is going to go in and take
jobs away from almost 6 million
Americans and then they're gonna take
away their unemployment insurance too so
what are they gonna do they're gonna
force those people to take the job that
the government wants them to take
guaranteed job Oh does isn't that great
hey guy we're gonna guarantee you a job
you know who else guarantees a job China
guarantees jobs for people you know who
else guaranteed job the Soviet Union
guaranteed you had the right to a job
actually not just the right you had you
needed to have the job you needed to
have to jump that the government gave
you and and it's really not a great idea
if you don't take that job you better do
a good job too you better make your boss
happy oh your boss can be pretty mean
when when you don't do a good job and
who's your boss here the most powerful
force ever devised the most powerful
political force on the face of the earth
ok part to diversify local and regional
communities with a particular focus on
communities where the fossil fuel
industry holds significant control over
the labor market diversify local and
regional economies what does that mean
it could mean one of two things you
either diversify it by the people or you
diversify it by the industry so in one
case you're moving people you're
forcibly moving people around to
different regions different places this
obviously has happened in every command
and control economy in the world in all
of history or you are diversifying the
industries that are there so you have a
command and control economy that is
saying nope I don't want there to be
this industry in Detroit I'm gonna take
that out I'm gonna replace it with this
because I Alexandria Ocasio Cortez know
much better how to run industry then the
people who run those industries and work
those industries and have family
different places and have different
economic incentives to move different
places hi Alexandra Oh Cassio Cortez I
studied economics at Boston University
and then I said I'm not the expert I
studied international relations but I'm
not the expert I Alexandria Cassio
Cortez I was a bartender for like a year
or something
and according to voter records lived
with my parents until a couple years ago
I know much better how to run every
single industry in the United States
then the people who run those industries
okay we're still in part two this is
section 4 of poor to ensure a just
transition for all workers low-income
communities communities of color
indigenous communities rural and urban
communities and the frontline community
is most affected by climate change what
what does any of that mean first of all
first of all just notice what they do
here they say just transition for all
workers so that could be the end of it
right because you've already got a
guaranteed job so everybody's a worker
it's the workers of America unite
everyone sure just transition for all
workers and then it names all of these
specific victim groups so-called victim
groups intersectionality groups
low-income communities of color
indigenous communities or the indigenous
communities non communities of color and
what's a community of color I don't and
urban communities what other what other
communities aren't this rural in there's
urban a suburb and exurban I don't know
and what is a just transition we're now
trusting Alexandria Ocasio Cortez to
give us a new definition of justice and
a transition listen to that language
that presumptuous language we're gonna
transition we're not good just going to
transition from one trade deal with
Mexico to another we're not just going
to transition from one sort of security
pact with a country to another no no
we're going to transition everything
your house your car your job your energy
where you live where you can live where
you can work what sort of job you we're
transitioning at but
Auri we the people who are gorgeous
saying right now that we're gonna take
away everything you have everything that
you have we are going to make sure
that's really just we clearly have a
good idea of justice don't we don't we
another timely sponsor we have got to
thank Lending Club if you are carrying
revolving debt that means you are not
paying off your credit card every month
you could be paying thousands in
interest every year that you don't have
to don't do this that people get stuck
on these high interest credit cards you
could deal with this in a much more
efficient way Lending Club will help you
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself and how much you want to borrow
just pick the terms that are right for
you and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days don't
be foolish and let your money you know
run away from you with high interest
credit cards do it right now Lending
Club is the number one peer-to-peer
lending platform with over 35 billion
dollars in loans issued go to Lending
Club home slash Knowles kena wles check
your eight minutes borrow up to forty
grand that's Lending Club com / Knowles
kena wala s Lending Club com / Knolls
Canada ble s all loans made by Webb bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender we get
into section number five here protect
and enforce sovereign rights and land
rights of tribal nations what what does
this have to do with protecting the
environment sovereign tribal mate we
yeah tribal nations have reservations
they're terrible places those people
should all come to America they would do
much better they would have a much
better life but they do exist
reservations do exist they're very very
sad places and I guess the green New
Deal is going to continue to allow
Native American reservations okay cool
whatever mitigate deeply entrenched
racial regional and gender-based
inequalities in income and wealth
including without
limitation ensuring the federal and
other investment will be equally
distributed to historically impoverished
low-income de-industrialized or other
marginalized communities in such a way
that builds wealth and ownership at the
community level
so this just means redistributing all of
the wealth held by anybody in this
country for any reason whatsoever that
Alexandria cassio Cortez sees fit what
this has to do with protecting the
environment we have no idea
mitigate deeply entrenched racial judge
blah blah blah blah blah not even just
income it's not even just raising taxes
its actual wealth confiscation that is
being listed in this draft legislation
take money from anybody we want for any
reason you race your sex they could say
okay yeah Asians have too much money all
Asian people need to give away 25% of
their wealth and we're gonna
redistribute it which really just keep
it for the government whether we
redistribute it to I don't know
black people or Hispanic people or
whatever because because though the
Asians they have too much money the
white people have too much money
never mind of course that there is never
mind that there is huge variation in the
wealth among different races do we it if
we're talking about the marginalized
community oppressed communities we're
gonna redistribute money to black people
say that seems to be the implication do
Beyonce and jay-z they get a check from
me because of historical discrimination
that's what this says I'm gonna have to
me Michael Knowles I'm gonna have to cut
a check to Beyonce Knowles who has I
don't know her combined wealth with
jay-z is what a billion dollars I'm
gonna have to cut a check for not just
my income for my wealth
because of historical discrimination
green New Deal that'll protect the
environment somehow there will be
additional measures including basic
income programs universal health care
programs and any others as the Select
Committee may seem appropriate may deem
appropriate
so now just universal health care alarm
they are saying we're going to allow the
possibility of universal health care
Reds socialist medicine as the committee
deemed
not as the legislature deems appropriate
not as a very estates deem appropriate
no no this power to govern your life and
death this power to govern what doctor
you go to see what medical insurance
you're allowed to there won't be any
more medical insurance the government
will control it all you don't even get
to make the decision as to whether or
not that happens one-sixth of the
American economy in the health care
system will be totally destroyed and
demolished by some committee that
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez sets up the
dictator okay she of course has she
Guara
and then this is my favorite part the
majority of financing of the plan shall
be accomplished by the federal
government using a combination of the
federal reserve and new public bank or
system of regional and specialized
public banks public venture funds and
such other vehicles or structures that
the Select Committee deems appropriate
and if you were confused by that you can
check in right now on the on the facts
the fa Q's here is a how are they going
to pay for this program the so the level
of investment required is massive even
if every billionaire and company came
together and were willing to pour all
their resources at their disposal the
aggregate value of the investments could
not be sufficient and the speed would be
massive so they're actually saying no
we're not just gonna tax the rich we're
gonna take away wealth from everybody or
or maybe they won't maybe they won't
take away the wealth from everybody the
way that they're going to do it is the
same way that we funded the second world
war it's the same way that we funded
quantitative easing the bank bailout
quantitative easing is the key here the
way that they're going to do it is by
printing money that's what she says when
she's talking about the Federal Reserve
and then we're gonna work with them
extending we're just gonna print money
it's gonna cost 40 trillion dollars so
we're just going to print money and then
truly but we are not caricature in this
ledger we've gone through it line by
line her plan for had to pay for it she
had
and come up with a better answer than I
don't know is we're gonna invent money
we're gonna print it out of the sky and
by the way just before we go to the sub
break I have got to point out she says
here the Green Deal has great momentum
92% of Democrats and 64% of Republicans
support the green year deal that isn't
true
this she got that statistic from the
Yale's program for climate change
communication study which it's true
those numbers are true from that study
the trouble with that study is that I
think the number is 82% of people yes
82% of respondents to that study had
never heard of the green new deal before
they asked the question so the way they
asked the question is this they said
quote some members of Congress are
proposing a green new deal
they say the green new deal will produce
jobs and strengthen America's economy by
accelerating the transition from fossil
fuels the deal would generate 100
percent of the nation's electricity from
clean renewable resources within the
next 10 years on and on and on so
basically the question is hey do you
support this really really great
legislation and then a lot of people say
yes that of course is not at all with
the green new deal is you just read what
it is and the people who were asked had
never heard of it it is a total lie
through and through and it's a lie to
take away every single thing you have
your car your job your money your house
your control over your own government it
is communism through and through that's
all it is and this is being pushed by
the super storm of the Democrat Party
speaking of the Democrat Party in just
one second will show you Joy Behar in
blackface because you know why not but
first we got a second about a Facebook
in YouTube make sure you come back for
the mailbag because that's coming up
right after this ten bucks a month
hundred dollars for an annual membership
you get me you get the Andrew Klavan
show gets Ben Shapiro serega test
question the mailbag you get the Matt
Walsh show you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom you
get all of that you get the leftist
here's tumblr the leftist here's tumblr
is very important you're going to have
to keep this and save all of your
leftist tears because once they push
through the green new deal and we're all
starving the only thing that you will be
able to sustain yourself on or the
leftist tears from how great our
politics is at the moment it could all
turn to trash if these people have
get power but for right now it's really
good so store up your left uh steers for
tomorrow for a rainy day or for a dry
day I guess and come on back in one
second we'll be right back with the
mailbag
now I'm sorry I want to get to the
mailbag as soon as possible but I just
can't do it without showing you joy
behar in blackface times they had an
op-ed piece in praise of naturally curly
hair they say that it's making a
comeback when it's like I've always had
curly that is all day in a statement huh
buddy oh you know this picture no I know
I was going I was so cute I was we are
you that is my word what you're in the
circle watch 29 it was a Halloween party
I went as a beautiful African woman oh
yes you ain't black don't you meet me
evidence so the whole point was really
wearing a me God that was I thought that
is made you have tanning lotion on a
little my head makeup that was a little
bit better than my hand
that's my actual hand I love it though
megyn kelly was kicked off of NBC News
for asking the question as to whether or
not it's may be acceptable to wear a
Diana Ross costume because you really
admire the singer and to dress up achill
II exactly like Joy Behar did there she
was immediately removed from NBC News
dragged throughout the press Joy Behar
still gets to be on the view a Ralph
Northam Democrat governor of Indiana
he's still the governor wore blackface
also defends infanticide he's still the
governor AG of Virginia also or
blackface in the eighties he's still the
AG of Virginia because being a Democrat
means never having to say that you're
sorry now look do I care about people
wearing racially or ethnically or
culturally tinged costumes well it
depends on the circumstances clear
obviously it depends on the
circumstances
that show you know they're talking about
this you've got different races of
cackling hens on the show um so I
shouldn't say that different races of
women on the show talking about it
nobody seems to really be offended by it
the circum and they let joy off the hook
for it okay all right whatever that's
fine but now we have this knee-jerk
reaction we have a knee-jerk one rule
for everything you can't wear a sombrero
you can't even eat a taco bowl if you
are a white person okay well if we're
gonna have one rule for everybody how
come the Democrats always get to break
the rule basically every single
prominent Democrat in the country within
the last week has admitted or is about
to admit that they were blackface in the
1980s if it were Republicans they would
probably be being tortured at Guantanamo
Bay right now but Democrats they get
away with it I'm not a fan of universal
one rule fits all cultural rules based
on faddish moral trends I'm not for that
I prefer a little grace I prefer a
little forgiveness too but if we're
gonna have it I think we have to hold
Democrats to the same standards let's
get to the mail bag from under my
glasses for the mail bag I need to oh
now I'm culturally appropriating Rachel
Maddow again from Dylan why do people on
the Left crave illegal immigration from
Central and South America in which most
people are religious Christians yet they
think Christians are backwards what
you're asking is the question of
intersectionality how is it that devout
even extreme Muslims and gay rights
activists can both unite together in the
intersectionality pyramid of oppression
to oppose Big Daddy America or something
when in many Muslim countries you see
people throwing gay people off of roofs
homosexuality is illegal how is that how
does that Joe it's because it has
nothing to do with reality itself it has
nothing to do with truth itself it has
nothing to do with the beliefs of these
people it has nothing even to do with
the actions of these people
it has to do with is perceived
oppression all it has to do actually is
with opposition to the perceived
oppressor and the perceived oppressor is
the Western tradition that's it the
perceived oppressor so the greatest
embodiment of that today is the United
States of America and I think where they
get their racism from is they picture
like a an old white guy as the face of
America if you look around America today
I don't think that's really fair to say
but that's what that's what they seen it
so they always go after the image of the
perceived oppressor is the
representative of the Western tradition
and if that means importing a bunch of
devout Christians into America they'll
do it because they don't they don't care
exactly about those contradictions they
just want to attack their perceived
oppressor from Amanda dear mr. Knowles
in a nutshell what is the difference
between Catholicism and Christian
orthodoxy can you play devil's advocate
and explain why orthodoxy is better kind
records Derek and Amanda Catholicism is
Christian orthodoxy I think what you're
referring to is Eastern Orthodoxy and
you're asking me to be the devil's
advocate by defending it no that's not
fair i I've you the west and the East as
the two lungs of Christianity there are
some theological differences one that
gets a lot of plays the Filioque the
Nicene Creed reads that the the Holy
Spirit proceeds from the father and the
son the Holy Spirit is the bond of love
between the father and the Son and the
Holy Spirit proceeds from the father and
the son riced will send this advocate to
you and the Eastern Orthodox Church as I
understand it believes that the Holy
Spirit proceeds only from the father and
this has a lot of other theological
implications there are relatively minor
theological differences between the west
and the east now I am Catholic because I
believe in the institution of the
Catholic Church I believe it's divinely
instituted by Christ I believe in the
line of succession from Peter who he
appoints to be his rock and which
builds his church and so I believe that
the Catholic Church is the Catholic
Church I think the evidence clearly
shows that however the Eastern Orthodox
Church has a lot going for it liturgical
II speaking almost in all places today
in the United States at least the
Eastern Orthodox Church has a much finer
liturgy a much more beautiful liturgy
they sing the whole liturgy the liturgy
is supposed to be sung it's much more
liturgical II serious it's a real
serious event of worshiping God you know
in the traditional Latin Mass that's a
very serious liturgy as well today now
we have the priests facing the people
oftentimes putting on what looks to be a
dying vaudeville show and they're just
they're often giving soft soap to people
what one theologian described as the the
homiletic saying well I might suggest
that you try to be a nice person you
know there's not a whole lot of serious
worship and you know when the priest
faces away from the rest of the parish
he is leading you in prayer and you are
all worshiping God together when he
turns around it makes it a little bit
more of a show a little bit more of a
performance when the liturgy is not sung
it allows for much more personality and
it'll it turns the priest oftentimes
into a two-bit actor at the very worst
so I really really admire the Eastern
Orthodox liturgy I still think that the
Catholic Church is the church but I pray
for the reunion of the East and West
because yeah it would be nicer to see a
full union of the two lungs of
Christianity from Austin hey Michael I
live in an area with a lot of homeless
people what do you think should be done
in cities with that struggle with large
homeless populations should it be
something that the government helps with
thanks bulldozers are one answer and I
mean that I'm only half-kidding we have
to at least bulldoze the tent cities
they're horrific they're a disgrace
they're illegal usually they are hazard
to both the people living around the
tent cities and to the people living in
them themselves there are a lot of drugs
there's a lot of rape there's a lot of
crime there's nothing compassionate
about people living on the
living on the streets is a dysfunctional
act that harms the individual and that
harms Society there are homeless
shelters there are a lot of homeless
shelters in a lot of places some are
privately run and some have been built
by the government that's good if you
need more of them maybe build some more
of them that's fine but very often
homeless people don't want to go to
those shelters because they're not
allowed to do drugs there they're not
allowed to do whatever they want there
they're not allowed to Panhandle and
make a bunch of money they're okay if
they're not willing to go to those
shelters than they need to be arrested
and put in prison and that's the choice
mayor Giuliani did a wonderful job in
New York cleaning up that city and he
did it by not tolerating people living
on the street and everybody was better
off because of it the people who were
homeless or formerly homeless often who
have mental problems or drug addictions
or whatever some of whom are just
selfish bums all of them were helped by
not letting them live on the street and
obviously the city was improved the
economy was improved the businesses were
more likely to come back their kids were
safer families were safer it was just a
much better place to live from irune
dear dr. koh feng which sport is more
american baseball or football baseball
much more American America's national
pastime
it's a much more sophisticated sport
it's a much more civilized sport it's
just a better sport all around from
Brendan o Catholic one my friends and I
were discussing same-sex marriage I said
that I believed a marriage required
sexual difference due to the ability to
procreate they said that to follow that
logic then men or women physically
unable to have children would not be
able to marry I'm stumped how do you
respond to that Thank You Brendan well
it does marriage requires sexual
difference but not exclusively because
of procreation there are a lot of other
reasons why sexual difference matters
men and women are different they
complement each other in more ways than
just the physical women tend to be more
nurturing they tend to have a more
greater emotional sensitivity men tend
to have a greater ability to
compartmentalize There is obviously a
psychological and spiritual
complementarity there as well plenty of
famous couples in history have had
trouble having children Abraham and
Sarah pretty good exam
11 I think but a lot of others as well
the ability to procreate is is not the
condition for marriage although one in
certainly in the Catholic Church if two
people cannot be married if one of them
is impotent if they can't have sex sex
is important to marriage and if if it's
not possible for you to have sex then
that is not a marriage but of course sex
that does not occur between a man and a
woman is by definition impotent it isn't
it doesn't bear any even logical
possibility to produce life so there's
an answer for you from Benjamin dear
master of the inkless pen as a Christian
I struggle with what my posture toward
abortion doctors and those that have had
or encouraged someone to have an
abortion should be to me they seem no
different than hitmen and those who have
put a hit out on someone is there a
difference Ben well there's a difference
in so much as perhaps they don't
understand the gravity of what they're
doing plenty of times we do things and
we don't understand the gravity of what
we're doing whereas for the Hitman it's
a little harder to misunderstand the
gravity of what they're doing that said
I know people who have murdered people
I'm friends with people who have
murdered people and turned their life's
or life around yes if you're live in New
York there's a good chance you know no
it's a stereotype so I think the way
that you approach these people is with
patience and grace that's always what we
do firmness in the truth but patience
and grace to bring them over to your
side of thinking from Jonathan dear
master of troller a destruction of the
Libs destructor of the libs I am avidly
pro-life however I have conflicting
ideas when it comes to rape or if the
mother's life is in legitimate risk what
do you think should be acceptable Thanks
came for Shapiro Clavin and Knowles
stayed for Shapiro Clavin and Knowles
but also listen to Walsh yes this is the
great would you allow for abortion in
the case of rape or a threat to the life
of the mother I'll give you my
philosophic answer
first and then my practical answer next
it's a baby regardless of how it was
conceived whether it was conceived in a
way that created a risk to the life of
mother or whether it was conceived
through rape it's still a baby and so
killing it is still killing it it's
still ending an innocent human life now
as for the life of the mother this is
greatly exaggerated there is as far as I
know no medical condition that requires
directly abortion some treatments of
medical conditions would as a side
effect kill the baby
that seems to me morally licit you're
not intending to kill the baby you are
treating a medical condition that
frankly could kill the mother and the
baby together as a result you put the
life of the baby at risk okay that's
possible now as a practical matter the
left always exaggerate this they say
well what about rape incest and life of
the mother okay rape incest and life of
the mother oh cause less than one
percent of all abortions so if you put a
bill forward you said we're gonna make
abortions illegal except in cases of
rape incest and life of the mother and I
could today end over ninety nine percent
of abortions in America of course I
would sign that bill I would sign it in
two seconds in a New York minute then we
can once we're past that part of
abortion on demand abortion for any
reason at all abortion because you don't
want your baby to have a disability
abortion because you don't want to right
rather raise a kid with a disability
abortion an hour after giving birth like
Ralph Northam suggests once we get the
parts that part of moral idiocy then we
can talk about the the question that
you've raised about rape incest and life
of the mother but from as a practical
matter call their bluff the left on this
ridiculous point end ninety nine percent
of abortions gladly okay and we have a
lot more to get to but we're at a time
so in the meantime I will see you on
Monday hopefully they'll be sounding
better and feeling better by then but in
the meantime I hope you also don't get
the flu and have a good weekend and I'll
see you on Monday I'm Michael knows this
isn't a Michael Nolt show
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19